It's time to work on
our weather app again.
It's time for
you to display some real data.
Well, sort of real data.
There are two parts to this task.
One, simulate the server injecting
the initial weather forecast
into the app js file.
You can copy the initial
weather forecast data
from the instructor notes below.
Second, modify the code to display the
weather data as soon as the app loads.
When you're done,
the app should load quickly and
immediately display
the initial weather data.
And, don't forget to try your
app in multiple browsers.
How does it work in Firefox,
Safari, etc?
Be sure to compare your app to the link
in the instructor notes below,
to make sure it works exactly the same.